porque estos países bálticos son puntos
estratégicos y qué mensaje cree que dan
no con su visita a ucrania
dan un doble mensaje buenos días a todos
de cercanía a europa de participación de
los países europeos en la contienda es
decir le dan la respuesta que putin
estaba buscando putin quería alejar a
ucrania de la democrática europa y los
países europeos se están acercando
quieren ser partícipes de la solución de
la contienda en ucrania fundamentalmente
es hacer llegar el apoyo anímico pero
también algo fundamental económico de
los países europeos sobre todo los
países más cercanos a ucrania que están
atendiendo ya a millones de refugiados
ucranianos en el suelo europeo y cuál ha
sido históricamente la relación de estos
países con rusia y qué repercusiones
cree usted que podría tener esta visita
en lo que son sus vínculos con el
kremlin
la vinculación que han tenido
fundamentalmente han formado parte del
mundo soviético tanto los países de la
antigua europa del este como el que
incluso aquellos países en las
repúblicas bálticas que pertenecieron
directamente a la unión soviética han
tenido unos lazos muy estrechos la
implosión de la unión soviética y la
independencia de las de las distintas
repúblicas
dibujaron un panorama geopolítico
totalmente distinto y rusia lo que está
intentando en los en los últimos meses
sino en los últimos años es recomponer
ese mapa y fundamentalmente recuperar la
senda neo imperial ya lo hizo en georgia
y armenia ya lo hizo con la
incorporación de crimea y ahora lo
trataba de hacerlo con una el
establecimiento de un protectorado en
ucrania igual que lo tiene en
bielorrusia y en casa están al frenar
esta expansión de una forma bélica ha
cometido tal vez uno de los de los
errores más graves geopolíticos en la
era putin y vamos a ver el
desencadenamiento pero en todo caso la
contienda como tal ya la ha perdido y
ahora con el anuncio de la vinculación
de finlandia y suecia a la otan
evidentemente se está consiguiendo
justamente lo contrario que lo que
perseguía precisamente hacia sí apunta
mi próxima pregunta a finlandia y suecia
como usted bien decía están pensando en
su ingreso a la otan está cambiando la
geopolítica de la región
está cambiando y está cambiando el
propio putin la agresión
absolutamente cruel dramática violenta
de los ejércitos rusos sobre el
territorio ucraniano lo que ha motivado
una de las mayores oleadas de refugiados
de la historia de europa sin parangón
desde la segunda guerra mundial lo que
está haciendo es acercar definitivamente
estos estos países al
círculo europeo y de defensa tanto de la
unión europea como de la otan esto
dibuja claramente un nuevo panorama
estratégico en el conjunto de europa